just when you thought democrat hypocrisy
couldn't sink any lower they trotted out
former president barack obama to try and
rescue terry mccauliff's floundering
campaign for virginia governor
so we're at a turning point
right now
both here in america and around the
world
because there's a mood out there we see
it right there there's a politics of
meanness
and division and conflict
of tribalism and cynicism
oh
he's against meanness
and division and conflict and tribalism
and cynicism so why did he say this in
the same speech
we don't have time
to be wasting
on these phony trumped up culture wars
this fake outrage
that right-wing media's pedals to juice
their ratings
fake outrage so a father protests his
daughter's school covering up the fact
that she was raped in a bathroom there
he's arrested not any of the school
bureaucrats who covered it up the father
whose daughter was raped he's arrested
smeared by msnbc and cnn and the media
is some kind of racist
then his case is used to smear parents
right across the country as domestic
terrorists which is in turn used by
biden's justice department to threaten
parents who protest woke indoctrination
in their schools with the fbi all by an
attorney general whose family is
profiting from the exact same woke
indoctrination that the parents are
protesting and obama calls it fake
outrage he condemns meanness and
division and conflict and tribalism and
cynicism if there's a worse example of
all those things than that speech by
obama let us know what it is
unlike obama i think it's important to
be fair so i'll say this
it's obvious that obama is a devoted
father and family man in that respect a
great role model
what would he have done what would he
have said
if it was one of his daughters
that had been raped at school in the
school covered it up we're talking about
the rape of a child and obama calls it
fake outrage that's not just an outrage
it's an obscenity and he dares to
criticize republicans for being mean and
cynical
i'm done with these democrats
pathological hypocrisy no more lectures
on hate and division from the people who
play the race card at every opportunity
no more lectures on misinformation from
the people who claim trillions of
dollars equals zero
no more lectures on compassion from the
people who incentivize human trafficking
no more lectures on saving democracy
from the people who push ballot
harvesting no more lectures on
gerrymandering
from the people who just carved up the
illinois congressional map to save their
own seats
no more lectures on climate from the
people who beg opec to pump more oil no
more lectures on the debt limit from the
people who voted against raising it time
after time after time no more lectures
from these democrats they're the ones
dividing america they're the ones
pushing hate for political power they're
the ones hurting the poorest and most
vulnerable they have no place on the
moral high ground and it's time we all
said so
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else